ray good morning how are you hello my
friend is there any outrage any anybody
upset about the Raiders you know filing
these relocation plans there is some but
it's not comparable to what charger fans
expressed when Dean Spanos picked up and
left for San Diego where for Los Angeles
I think they're sort of resigned to it I
mean this has been this talk has been
three years building not necessarily for
Vegas but for LA and then there was a
brief flirtation with San Antonio he's
been looking Mark Davis has been looking
to get out for 43 years at least if not
more so I think there's sort of this
weariness about it I think there's a
sense of inevitability I think they had
some hope when los angeles the los
angeles vote went against him a year ago
but then he turned around and he cobbled
together a deal that is hard for the
other owners to dislike you and so I
think for the most part we're just going
well this sucks they're finally good now
they're leaving but isn't that our lot
in life how does it not happen it
doesn't happen if we have underestimated
the owners resistance to mark davis's
charms but I think that has worn down as
it's become increasingly clear that not
only did he do a deal they didn't think
he could get done in Vegas but that the
the Oakland response has been so you
know not to the league's liking I mean
the league didn't want the fortress
group which is the money people who were
going to handle the construction of the
stadium to be involved they wanted to
control that themselves and I think
they're sort of looking at this now as
though they really don't have an
alternative but to move because we don't
like the Oakland deal so I think it's
going to be hard for owners who maybe
just don't think that Mark Davis should
have Las Vegas to make a compelling
argument to keep them out what a Raider
fans do
I would say somewhere between five and
eight thousand will probably make tener
airplane flights a year because I look
if they don't do that then Davis's whole
idea about how Vegas can be viable takes
a huge hit because he needs he needs
transplants from the Bay Area and he
needs transplants from LA until they can
build up their own sort of independent
fan base so I'm guessing yes somewhere
in not 10,000 I don't think it'll be
that many but i'd say somewhere between
55 and 8,000 wouldn't make those trips
because flights to vegas are relatively
cheap more painful the tuck rule game
car breaking his leg or yesterday the
relocation papers filed for vegas of the
three the tuck rule is probably least
painful because at least then they could
wrap themselves around the notion that
the NFL somehow deliberately screwed
them and there's nothing that fuels your
day quite like a conspiracy theory
whereas a car was bad luck and I think
that's the one that may bother them the
most right now because they thought they
had a Super Bowl quality team or at
least one that could contend for it did
you throw i would say in in order the
car one bothers them the most followed
by this followed by the Tuck roll in
some ways I think they're happy about
the Tuck roll because it reinforces
everything they've always believed about
themselves and about the lead he's ray
Ratto Comcast Sports Net Bay Area
joining a Stan Patrick show I was musing
about the Golden State Warriors and I've
watched a lot of them this year and I
wondered and I do wonder do they have
too many stars can you have too many
stars on a team um mother I mean there's
thirty six and six yes oh they've
overcome that party pretty well but it's
weird to watch you know Korea's is the
one who has taken a dip here and and I
get the feeling it he was leading the
charge hey come on here KD will take
care of you you blend in have fun it
almost feels like he he hasn't found his
game where everybody else I guess is
finding their game
no I don't know what it is with curry
but he's come back down to earth why do
you think that is I think in part
because teams have taken on what
Cleveland did in the finals which was
really body up on him and put a guy on
him no matter what is happening
elsewhere on the court so I think
they've they've been more assiduous in
trying to take him out of his game
beyond that there there aren't a lot of
real differences except that this team
is being graded on margin of victory if
they only win by 12 the issue is why are
they coming apart yeah you know I mean
like I said I mean when and when they do
lose they get blown out I mean they they
very rarely lose a close game but for
the most part we're talking about
parsing six losses and a number of games
in which they didn't win by 20 so
basically the bar has been raised for
them as though you know Durant was going
to come in and the adjustment would be
seamless which it hasn't been I mean
they weren't going to go to 135 points a
game just because they included him on a
team that wasn't going to have to make
any other changes I just think they're
there at the back end of adjusting to
Durant and he to them but for the most
part I think curry is because teams have
figured out we can actually at least
keep him in check where we couldn't
figure out how to do it before I think
that's the difference in curries numbers
LeBron refusing to acknowledge a rivalry
with the Warriors means what means that
he's lying to us it's probably the only
viable rivalry yeah in the NBA right now
yeah Oklahoma City was going to be that
but Oklahoma City is Russell Westbrook
and the Clippers are going to be that
but they came and went I think I think
people will be viscerally disappointed
if the finals aren't Cleveland and
Golden State again if somehow Erato got
through or if San Antonio beat the
Warriors I think a lot of people would
be really bummed so I think you know
LeBron could say what he wants I mean he
can you can live in the alternate
universe where there are no rivalries
but this is a rivalry
and you just saw one of the reasons why
which is draymond Green you know sort of
typed out a message to leave on his
forehead and I think you're going to see
more of that and if they play seven
times in a row again you you're going to
find out what a rivalry is it's it's
going to be celtics lakers level because
there aren't any other alternatives this
is it oh there isn't if this isn't a
rivalry there is not I'll leave you with
this if I'm a niner fan give me a pep
talk in five years they won't have moved
I can't I there there is no evidence
right now that will excite anybody
because on the one hand while the Kyle
Shanahan deal is pretty much done unless
he gets cold feet they don't have a
general manager yet and nobody's quite
sure how that general general manager is
going to work they've got to rebuild the
entire roster I mean they are where the
Raiders were four years ago and it took
it took the raiders four years to dig
out this is going to be a long involved
process and the only thing that keeps
49er fans warm at night is there
visceral hatred of Jed York if they
didn't have that the despair would be
just all-encompassing they have hatred
and hatred can keep you warm when you
run out of liquor have a good weekend
rate thanks for joining us and you as
well that's ray ratto Comcast Sports Net
Bay Area the Dan Patrick show weekday
morning on audience
[Music]